actor mark islands earned an Academy
Award for his portrayal of a Soviet spy
in the 2015 movie bridge of spies
violence is back on the big screen in
the world war ii drama
Dunkirk the movie focuses on the 1940
rescue of more than 300,000 British and
Allied soldiers from the beaches of
Dunkirk in northern France violence
plays mr. Dawson a civilian who crosses
the English Channel in his own boat to
help rescue stranded troops from the
approaching German army Thunder aah
oh we have a job to do this is this is a
pleasure yo yo yo yo we can say let's
not a bloody Navy man your age and my
age dictate this war why should we be
allowed to send our children to fight it
should be at home well it won't be me
home if we allow a sorter across the
channel Christopher Nolan wrote and
directed the movie and it's getting very
positive reviews and is considered an
early Oscar contender rolling stone
called Dunkirk a landmark with a
resonant force of an enduring screen
classic sir Mark Rylance joins us at the
table welcome what a pleasure thank you
I saw the movie last night and at the
IMAX ID the IMAX yes and I think that
scene captured it so well because the
British soldier says what are you doing
go home yet he's drawn to go help what
drew you to that role it's a very famous
group of people in England the the
thousand or more men who answer
Churchill's call to go across on any
available boat they can find and help
ferry this the soldiers who are trapped
on the beach out to the bigger boats
because the water is so shallow because
even a man who goes across in a canoe
and they shout down to him what the hell
are you doing here he says I've got one
seat in back because there were 400,000
soldiers waiting and it was Dunkirk
Churchill thought they'd only get 30,000
back and they got over 300,000 back
you're a legendary because of your
portrayals of different Shakespearean
characters how did you prepare for this
for this yes I we have a we're so
successful at war in England we have a
museum for the Imperial War Museum or
we're successful being imperious yes and
you can go there and they're lovely
recordings that they made before the
fellows passed away so I listen to audio
tapes of the men who went across and did
this thing listening for what I'm
missing for the the tone of society is
different at that time there's a
selflessness and they belief in communal
effort
and togetherness that's a little bit
different than England now I'm answering
the call of duty yeah I know answer the
call of duty and just knowing what they
didn't know they they weren't told of
course by the government that they're
never going to be bombed and shot at
they were told that there were men there
who needed to be rescued so it's it's
important to know what your character
could know might know and might not know
societies and warfare obviously have
evolved and changed since then but
something that really struck you was the
civilian casualty numbers and how we
continue to see them in plights around
the world today and something this movie
really focuses on as well the civilians
who perish and the civilians who were
brave enough to go in and try to rescue
people as well yeah I'm told 90% of
casualties in war across the world are
civilian now 90 percent whereas in 1900
it was 10 percent and but now in some
ways you're safer in the military and so
many of the attacks take place not on
battlefields like Waterloo or wherever
but you know at concert halls and in the
streets of London so we're witnessing in
England and here everywhere
extraordinary bravery by civilians and
rescue services of course in that kind
of thing but this was a rare a very
unusual battle where the civilians go
and rescue the military people the
military people are stranded and but
he's distilled that you know it's not a
history lesson he's distilled it to an
essential experience has any of people
who are longing to get home and can't
get home how they'd managed to do so I
think you're exactly right and and you
know also I think portrays how many we
forget how we send our young men and
women to die sweetly actors and when
you're witness what they what the poor
young the terrible deaths of so many
young men yeah and one of the actors
Harry Styles you know from one direction
I'm there at the premiere last night
there were a lot of young women cheering
and screaming oh he's marvelous isn't it
he is and it's this is I guess his first
acting debut it did you know in LA when
we were doing price someone pointed out
that Elvis and Eminem and some of the
other people have gone into film they've
gone in at a lead role because of course
who wouldn't have them in their film
everyone's going to come but he's coming
to an ensemble of a wide group of actors
and taking a humble in a very difficult
part and he
he's a delightful young man very witty
I'm very lucky to work alongside you
thank you thank you so much for joining
us done truck opens in theaters and IMAX
on Friday if you're watching CBS this
morning we'll be right back